[Música]
[Aplausos]
hola chicos chicas primero agradecer al
equipo realmente estoy muy emocionada
por estar acá hoy les voy a hablar de un
tema que es súper importante que es
urgente además para esto quiero pedirles
que por favor cierren los ojos todos y
los estoy viendo por si acaso cierren
los ojos y quiero que vayan a un momento
muy específico quiero que se vayan a un
momento con su ex pareja con su pareja
actual un momento de pelea
quiero que se acuerden de ese momento
que lo vivan que sientan ese es el rol
de ese dolor que tenemos cuando peleamos
quiero que se acuerden de que si alguna
vez han perdonado algo por amor
acuérdense que también
acuérdense de si alguna vez han estado
dispuestos a renunciar a algo por amor
tal vez lo han hecho tal vez han dejado
amigos han dejado a la familia han
dejado un trabajo por amor
les pido que abran los ojos
tengan ese sentimiento muy muy presente
durante toda la charla porque hoy les
voy a hablar de por qué ese sentimiento
que tenemos vinculado al amor que hemos
básicamente ligado como sinónimo de amor
no es algo natural y mucho menos puede
denominarse amor
durante mucho tiempo y obviamente basada
en mis experiencias personales me he
puesto a pensar en por qué
y de donde además viene esta idea de que
el amor es sufrimiento vivimos así
personalmente nuestras experiencias de
pareja generalmente hay un vínculo real
con el sufrimiento durante ese proceso
de averiguar qué ha pasado y por qué y
de dónde viene encontrado un concepto
fundamental que me ha ayudado a orientar
una serie de reflexiones que han
derivado en que básicamente sea
feminista
este es el concepto amor romántico pero
estas se preguntarán que es el amor
romántico es un concepto que es
básicamente esto que que nos han dicho
que es el amor romántico que es que tu
chico te abra la puerta que te regalen
flores que te hagan una sorpresita
etcétera etcétera etcétera pues no el
amor romántico al parecer y no al
parecer de hecho en realidad es un
modelo de amor al ser un modelo de amor
quiere decir que obviamente hay otros
modelos no este modelo de amor lo que
básicamente hace es mostrarnos y
enseñarnos culturalmente e
históricamente también
que ciertos comportamientos que que
tenemos en una relación de pareja y que
tenemos de manera colectiva frente al
amor son algo básicamente natural y que
además de estos comportamientos son algo
repetitivos es por eso que muchas de
nuestras relaciones van a tener ciertas
situaciones muy similares a lo largo de
su proceso
el amor romántico está fundamentado en
una idea o en algo que como sociedad
también hemos creado que es súper
importante que son los mitos
los mitos que son básicamente la forma
en la que como seres humanos explicamos
las cosas que sentimos o que no
entendemos como el amor
se van arraigando en nuestros
pensamientos personales y colectivos
como
de repente hacen que estos sentimientos
que no entendemos puedan ser entendidos
como naturales un ejemplo del caso es
que esta idea de que el amor todo lo
puede de que el amor todo lo perdona y
además esta idea de que el amor es algo
natural igual
estos mitos van metiéndose en nuestra
cabeza y generan ideas colectivas que
básicamente hacen que entendamos que el
amor es algo natural pero no el amor no
es algo natural
hace el amor romántico para meterse en
nuestros pensamientos he encontrado otro
concepto
el amor romántico básicamente
se mete en nuestros nuestros
pensamientos a través de productos
culturales
qué es un producto cultural los
productos culturales son básicamente
todas este material que vamos
consumiendo a lo largo de nuestra vida
consume en qué sentido por ejemplo
nosotros vemos novelas yo apuesto que la
mayoría ha visto novelas vemos películas
tenemos la música tenemos el arte
tenemos la literatura todos estos
materiales hacen que nosotros
legitimemos ciertas ideas de
comportamiento en nuestra cotidianidad
entonces para explicarles bien qué es un
producto cultural he preparado un par de
ejemplos quiero que miren bien esa
imagen
en esta imagen es una imagen de una
novela una novela mexicana que se llama
marimar porque es como marimar porque yo
siento y es evidenciado claramente que
como jóvenes o por lo menos las
generaciones que estamos aquí sentados
hemos consumido muchas novelas mexicanas
evidentemente esto no es algo sólo de
las novelas mexicanas están las
brasileras están las turcas está en un
montón esta escena que es una escena
complicada quisiera decirles graciosa
pero me parece complicada básicamente lo
que les voy a contar lo que sucede
thalía una chica en condición de pobreza
en marimar obviamente
está en la playa está en su casa
etcétera aparece la típica chica mala
porque acuérdense que siempre hay una
chica mala apareciendo un caballo y de
repente le dice bueno
le comienza a charlar y le dice marín
márquez bla bla bla que eso ha pasado
que jose antonio me estoy inventando el
nombre por si acaso no lo he visto
completamente la novela marimar que esto
que pasa hablo la cndh y le dice una
frase muy específica si tú quieres
realmente a josé miguel vas a recoger
este collar o esta manía no me acuerdo
bien que es del suelo y del barro
marimar claro que sí como todas nosotras
y nosotros en un acto muy desprendido de
amor se lanza con la boca al lodo y lo
levanta
yo he quedado así de que porque la
reflexión de esto es que básicamente no
importa que no importa hasta dónde sino
que estamos dispuestos a pasar una serie
de conflictos y sufrimientos a nombre de
que del amor porque así no los han
enseñado
otro ejemplo
al que voy a ir es a las películas de
disney no son las únicas películas que
legitiman el amor romántico esta imagen
es una renuncia igual terrible sirenita
renuncia hace a su naturaleza por estar
con otra persona por estar además con un
modelo específico de persona que ya les
voy a hablar bien del de las
expectativas otro producto cultural
definitivamente es la música
se los voy a leer a mí me gustan mayores
de esos que llaman señores de los que te
abren la puerta claro y te mandan flores
y yo sé que conmigo estás mejor todo
guti o christian dior te llevo
chocolates una flor baby yo te hago el
sexo y el amor acuérdense de esto y de
estas frases porque son básicamente lo
que cantamos en los boliches en todos
los boliches y si no están en su
playlist de spotify acuérdense bien
porque estos son básicamente los modelos
que estamos siguiendo y esto es lo que
buscamos si buscamos un chico que sea
super bueno en la cama si buscamos un
chico que sea súper proveedor que nos
esté pagando las cuentas y claro que si
las chicas implícitamente o los chicos
en realidad están buscando pues chicas
que cumplan con el estereotipo de
belleza y con otras condiciones más
acuérdense de las de esto porque porque
los productos culturales básicamente lo
que hacen es legitimar algo que también
nos está regulando subconscientemente
que son las expectativas qué papel
juegan las expectativas dentro del amor
uno muy un muy muy importante claro las
expectativas básicamente condicionan
nuestros comportamientos nuestro deber
ser frente a otra persona y el deber ser
de la otra persona frente a nosotros lo
que hacemos en una relación de pareja es
básicamente tomarnos de la mano decidir
caminar por la vida y creamos una
burbuja enorme esta burbuja enorme tiene
una serie de cargas culturales ahí
ponemos todas las expectativas de él de
mí de mí hacia él y del colectivo y
generamos una simbiosis tal
que básicamente nos volvemos personas
marginales en este proceso renunciamos
absolutamente a todo renunciamos a algo
que es trascendental para tener una
relación de pareja y es la idea de que
básicamente tenemos tenemos que entregar
el 50-50 en una pareja y decidimos
a través de los mitos legitimar que es
normal que nosotros entreguemos más que
nuestra pareja y que a esto además le
podemos denominar amor pero el escenario
puede ser un poco más complejo a donde
quiero llegar con esto
nosotros como jóvenes estamos
desenvolviendo nos en nuevas esferas del
relacionamiento la principal claro que
sí son las redes sociales
como están funcionando las redes
sociales ahora en el amor romántico o
cómo funciona el amor romántico en las
redes sociales
funciona de dos maneras la primera es
que básicamente las redes sociales se
convierten en un legitimador y
amplificador de las expectativas
entonces tenemos a gente subiendo la
típica foto del gimnasio por ejemplo al
chico que sube la típica foto del
gimnasio que incluso puede no ser de él
pero si tiene que mostrar que está
cargando por lo menos unos 45 kilos
tener brazos súper fuertes acuérdense de
lo que tenemos que hacer y las chicas
por el otro lado estamos subiendo
imágenes también ya un poco más de
nuestros cuerpos legitimando el modelo
de belleza que tenemos que seguir para
hacer unas buenas mujeres dentro de una
relación de pareja
las plataformas digitales no sólo se
quedan en esta en este ser una nueva
vitrina para reforzar las expectativas
van un poco más allá y están
fortaleciendo que sean posibles
diferentes tipos de violencia entonces
va a ser de repente muy normal que los
chicos saquen fotos sin consentimiento a
las chicas con las que se han acostado y
las envíen a sus grupos de whatsapp para
que para legitimar un comportamiento que
forma parte de este ideal del amor
romántico en este caso la virilidad va a
ser muy normal que tengas chicos que
estas chicas también que te están
acosando en redes sociales a nombre del
amor que tengas gente que es básicamente
capaz de acostarte capaz de chantajear
te con tus fotos desnuda capaz de
paralizar tus fotos desnuda
de repente las redes sociales se están
convirtiendo en un amplificador de la
violencia
este escenario es complejo es complejo
desde las expectativas porque qué pasa
cuando cuando realmente estamos con una
pareja pues de repente estamos con una
pareja hemos creído en todas las
expectativas pasan unos tres o cuatro
meses donde realmente te conoces y
conoces un poco más a profundidad lo que
es la otra persona y te pegas un golpe
tan duro que comienzas a vincular
el amor al sufrimiento
te pegas un golpe tan duro porque porque
somos seres complejos pues somos seres
diferentes complejos y no en ningún
momento vamos a cumplir con las
expectativas que este modelo de amor nos
ha enseñado que debemos buscar y por el
otro lado las redes sociales incluso
están comenzando a convertirse en un
espacio en el que proponemos promover
discursos de odio o sea no nos quedamos
no es suficiente para nosotros agarrar y
compartir las imágenes desnudas de
nuestra chica sino que comenzamos una
ola de discursos capas creamos una
página o algo por el estilo para para
realmente darle duro no esto es parte de
una situación y de una lógica de
violencia una lógica de violencia que
está siendo más fluida por las redes
sociales y que puede derivar en muchos
casos incluso en la muerte de una
persona no se olviden y acuérdense bien
que muchos de los feminicidios en
bolivia están justificados por los celos
y los celos que vienen de esta idea
tonta
de que los celos son una forma de amor
yo no les quiero dejar con este
escenario tan complejo y con esta
desesperanza que a veces sentimos porque
eso se siente cuando uno entiende estos
temas desesperanza es así es como
desolación yo lo siento permanentemente
lo que me he puesto a pensar es que que
se puede hacer que podemos hacer como
jóvenes para cambiar esta situación
una palabra condensa básicamente lo que
creo que podemos hacer y en resistencia
pero resistencia que resistencia todo
claro resistencia a los modelos que nos
han impuesto resistencia a entender que
tenemos que vivir bajo las expectativas
acuérdense el amor es algo enseñado y
estas expectativas claro que sí tienen
que ser reconstruidas resistencia a
promover nuevas formas de violencia en
plataformas digitales
la resistencia se puede hacer digital
también resistencia a creer que el amor
es algo natural el amor es algo
aprendido comencemos a través de
pequeñas acciones a cambiar
resignificamos el concepto de amor
entendiéndolo como un arma de
resistencia porque si chicos
definitivamente hay algo en lo que creo
el amor le puede dar la vuelta al
sistema gracias
[Aplausos]